สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนค่ะนักเรียนกลับมาพบกับครูฟ้า
แล้วก็ครูเรียมนะคะในวดีโอ beginner  4
นะ 4 นะคะนักเรียค่ะในช่อง comprehensible
Thai นะคะทุกคน comprehensible ไยค่ะใช่
แล้วใช่ค่ะวันนี้เราเจอกันเกี่โมงคะครูปา
วันที่ก่อนมั้ยอ้าได้ๆๆๆ
วันโอควันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธค่ะวันพุธวัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
28  28 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายนกันยายนเดี๋ยวเรียมขอเขียนแบบย่อ
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 แล้วปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะ
อืมกี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 14
น 34
น 34 นาทีอเรียมว่านาฬิกาเรียมไม่ตรง
นะเหมือนแบบต้องปรับเออต้องเปลี่ยน
แบตเตอรี่อ่ะต้องเปลี่ยนอเปลี่ยน
แบตเตอรี่เหรอใช่เพราะแบบตอนนี้กี่โมง
แล้วเนี่ย
ประมาณ 14:00 น 1420 กว่า
อ 1420 ไม่ใช่เป็นประมา
1434 เช้าอืเช้าไปประมาณ 10  13 นาทีเออ
ครูเมอาจจะต้องเปลี่ยนแบตเตอรี่แล้วนะคะ
ใช่ต้องเปลี่ยนถ่านนะคอืๆๆใช่ๆนั่นแหละ
แต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยครูเรียมเป็นยังไงสบาย
ดียคะสบายดีค่ะครูป๊าวันนี้ฝนตกออกไปข้าง
นอกก็เลยได้เล่นน้ำฝนนิดหน่อยโอ้เล่นน้ำ
ฝนระวังไม่สบายนะใช่มเวลาฝนตกแล้วเนี่ย
เราโดนฝนเราจะไม่สบายนะคะจริงเหรอคะครู
ฟ้าตอนเด็กๆเรียมก็เล่นน้ำฝนบ่อยๆนะได้
หรอตอนเด็กครูฟ้าได้เล่นมยตอนเด็กครูฟ้า
ก็ไม่ค่อยได้เล่นน้ำฝนเลยอ่ะจริงเหรอ
เพราะกลัวไม่สบาย
อืตอนเด็กๆชอบค่ะเมื่อไหร่ที่ฝนตกเรียมก็
อืมีซันไลละเรมก็เอซันไลน์ราดพื้นแล้วก็
สไลเดอร์สไลเดอร์แปลว่าฮูเรเนี่ยตอนเด็กๆ
ชอบเล่นน้ำำฝนใช่มยน้ำฝนน้ำฝนน้ำฝนใช่ชอบ
ตอนนี้เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าไม่ไม่ได้เล่นน้ำฝนเลย
ค่ะครูเรียมเพราะครูฟ้าชอบร้องเพลงอยู่ใน
บ้านมากกว่าหรอ
อ๋อนี่ไงครูฟ้าตอนเด็กๆร้องเพลงในบ้านใช่
มยวันนี้เรียมได้เล่นน้ำฝนเรียมก็เลยเออ
นึกถึงตอนเด็กๆเออเราได้ทำอะไรบ้างนะก็มี
นะก็มีเพลงที่เราร้องกันตอนเด็กๆแล้ว
เรียมเชื่อ
ว่าเด็กหลายๆคนร้องได้หรอใช่เพลงที่ร้อง
ตอนเด็กๆใช่มเพราะว่าครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบร้อง
เพลงนะคะครูเรียมก็ชอบร้องเพลงตอนเด็กๆ
ทุกคนน่าจะชอบร้องเพลงมยใช่เรียมเรียมคิด
ว่าเด็กทุกเรียมว่าเด็กทุกคนในห้องเรียน
เพื่อนของเรียมทุกคนนะคะที่เรียนมาด้วย
กันชอบร้องเพลงนะตอนเด็กๆ
อืแต่ไม่มีใครคิดว่าใครร้องเพลงดีหรือไม่
ดีอะไรแบบเนี้ยตอนเด็กๆอ่ะเนาะแต่พอโต
ขึ้นมาบางคนก็บอกว่าอร้องเพลงไม่ไม่ได้โอ
เอ้อแปลกมากเลยเนาะเออแปลกมากค่ะมันอืตอน
เด็กก็แบบร้องได้ทุกคนเราไม่เห็นมีใครบอก
บอกเลยว่าแบบหนูร้องเพลงไม่ได้ค่ะผมร้อง
เพลงไม่ได้ครับเว่าเด็กไม่มีนะอืมตอนเด็ก
ๆยังไม่คิดอะไรไงใช่มยมันยังเค้าเรียกว่า
อินโนเซนเนาะคนไทยก็อาจจะพูดอินโนเซนนะคะ
ให้ร้องเพลงก็ร้องคิดว่าเด็กๆทุกคนก็ชอบ
ร้องเพลงนั่นแหละอืมใช่ใช่ๆแล้วตอนเด็กๆ
เรียมเรียนอยู่ที่มหาสารคามอือยู่ที่บ้าน
บ้านอยู่ที่จังหวัด
มหาสารคามอไม่ใช่จังหวัดเชียงใหม่ไม่ใช่
หัวหินเอ้ยไม่ใช่ภูเก็ตไม่ใช่กระบี่อื
อยู่
มหาสารคามใช่แล้วครูฟ้าล่ะคะตอนเด็กๆครู
ฟ้าอยู่จังหวัดอะไรครูฟ้าอยู่จังหวัด
ชลบุรีค่ะจังหวัดชลบุรีแล้วก็พัทยานัก
เรียนหลายๆคนจะรู้จักพัทยาใช่มยพัทยาอยู่
ในจังหวัดชลบุรีอันนี้ชลบุรีแล้วก็จะมี
พัทยาออฟ้าอยู่พัทยาจังหวัดชนบุรีเราไม่
ได้อยู่ในจังหวัดเดียวกันนะ
ไม่คนละ
จังหวัดเดี๋ยววันนี้เรียมจะลองร้อง
เพลงที่เรียมแล้วก็เพื่อนๆร้องตอนเด็กๆดู
ซิว่าเด็กที่อยู่ในในจังหวัดมหาสารคามกับ
เด็กที่อยู่ในจังหวัดชลบุรีอือจะร้องเพลง
เดียวกันได้มยนั่นน่ะสิครูเรียมร้องเพลง
เยอะ
มยเยอะนะเหมือนเหมือนเพลงแรกอ่ะเพลงแรก
ที่เรียมจะร้องก็คือ 1  2
3 ปลาฉลามขึ้นบก
อ๋อเ้าครูฟ้าทำไมอ๋อล่ะออหรือเปล่า
เพลงนี้ร้องว่าอะไรนะคะครูเลียมเราเรา
ต้องร้องให้นักเรียนฟังมั้ย 1  2  3 ปลา
ฉลามขึ้นบกอื 4  5  6 จิ้งจกยัด
ไส้เคยได้ยินมั้ยเคยได้ยินเคยได้
ยินเหมือนแบบแอมเชอรี่จั๊กะจี้หัวใจ
เออแล้วก็อะไรนะไอ้แอมตกบันไดเพราะไอ้หมา
ตัวนี้
ใช่มมันเป็นเพลงที่ิ่งมันค่อนข้างงงนิด
นึงมีความหมายแบบมันคืออะไรหรอ
อะไเออแต่ว่าเราได้ยินเพื่อนร้องแล้วก็
เออเพื่อนแล้วก็ร้องอยู่ทั้งวันน่ะครูฟ้า
อือๆๆ 1  2  3 เออจำได้อ้าครูฟ้าก็ร้อง
ได้ใช่มยเพลงนี้ครูฟ้าร้องได้ค่ะตอนเด็กๆ
เหมือนมันจะเป็นเกมหรืออะไรสักอย่างนึง
มั้งที่มีเด็กๆใช่มั้ยครูฟ้าเป็นเด็กแล้ว
ก็มีเพื่อนๆๆๆเล่นกัน
มั้งไม่รู้อ่ะไม่ชัวร์แต่ครูฟ้าร้องร้อง
เพลงนี้ได้นะคะใช่เด็กๆหลายๆคนรู้จักแล้ว
บางทีเราน่ะรู้จักเพลงแบบเนี้ยตอนเด็ก
แล้วเราก็ไม่ได้คิดว่าเราร้องถูกหรือร้อง
ผิดอืเราก็ร้องไปเรื่อยๆเราก็ไม่ได้คิดนะ
ว่ามันมีความหมายว่าอะไร
อืซึ่งิมคิดว่ามันตลกมากเลยเราแค่พูดูด
ออกมาแต่เราก็ไม่รู้ว่าเอ้ออะไรอ่ะมันเอา
ไปทำอะไรเพลงนี้ไม่รู้อืมันไม่มีิ่งอะไร
นะคะมันไม่เข้าใจด้วยนะนักเรียน 1  2  3
ปลาฉลามขึ้นบก 1  2  3 ไม่นักเรียนเข้าใจ
อยู่แล้วเจะ 4  5  6 จิ้งจกยัดไส้ไอแอม
เชอรี่จักจี้หัวใจไอแอมตกบันไดเพราะไอ้
หมาตัวตัวนี้อันนี้คือเพลงนะคะซึ่งครูฟ้า
ร้องเพลงเมื่อกี้แล้วครูฟ้าก็ไม่เข้าใจ
เอ้ออะไรนะก็เออแเข้าเออมาคิดตอนโตเนี่ย
ว่าเฮ้ยร้องอะไรนะ 1  2  3 ปลาฉลามปลาปลา
ฉลามที่อยู่ในทะเลนะขึ้นมาบนบกขึ้นมาบนบก
ขึ้นมาทำไมขึ้นมาทำไมไม่รู้แล้วก็ 4  56
จิ้งจกที่มันตัวเล็กๆอ่ะที่อยู่ในบ้านเรา
จิ้งจกยัดไส้โอ้อะไรไปใส่ท้องจิงจกเหรอ
ออไม่รู้แต่มันเป็นเพลงที่เด็กๆชอบนะคะ
เด็กๆชอบแล้วก็สนุกไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนมี
เพลงนี้ไมอ่ะเนาะคิดว่าอาจจะเป็นเมโลดี้
เหมือนกันแต่ว่าอาจจะเป็นภาษาอังกฤษหรือ
เปล่าใช่อาจจะเป็นเพลงอะไรสักอย่างที่
เป็นภาษาของนักเรียนเองอืมมีมที่แบบชอบ
ร้องนะตอนเด็กๆแต่ก็ไม่รู้เหมือนกันว่า
ร้องเพื่ออะไร
อือๆใช่แต่เพลงนี้ครูฟ้ารู้จักค่ะครู
เรรียนครูเรียนมีเพลงอื่นมยเรียนว่าเพลง
ที่นักเรียนของเราน่าจะแบบรู้จักนะที่เรา
ร้องคนไทยร้องตอนเด็กๆแล้วก็นักเรียนที่
เรียนภาษาไทยรู้จักก็คือช้างชชชชอ๋ออเพลง
ช้างอ่ะงั้นต้องร้องให้นักเรียนฟังก่อนนะ
คะครูเรียมูฟ้าอ๋อเลยอ่ะฟ้าอ๋อเลยนัก
เรียนก็จะรู้จักมยพอรู้จักใช่มันจะร้อง
ว่าช่างๆชชๆน้องเคยเห็นช้างหรือเปล่าช่าง
มันตัวโตไม่เบาจมูกยาวๆเรียกว่างวงมี
เขี้ยวใต้งวงเรียกว่างามีหูมีตาหางยาว
เพลงนี้เหมาะกับการเรียนภาษาไทยมาก
เลยใช่นักเรียนเออนักเรียนไปฟังเพลงนี้นะ
คะเนี่ยเพลงนี้เนี่ยมีภษภาษาไทยเยอะเลยนะ
คะนักเรียฟังฟังภาษาไทยนเรียก็จะรู้ใช่
มั้ยช้างใชแต่มันมี 2 เวอร์ชั่นนะหมายถึง
ของครูเรียนเป็นเวอร์ชั่นช่างๆๆๆๆใช่มั้ค
คว่าช่างๆ
ๆแต่ว่าข้างหลังเหมือนกันมยเหมือนกันค่ะ
ก็เหมือนกันน้องเคยเห็นช่างหรือเปล่าช่าง
มันตัวโตไม่เบาใช่ไหมมเหมือนกันออืก็คือ
เพลงนี้เาจะถามว่าช้างช้างๆชๆช้างก็คือ
ช้างนะคะน่าจะรู้จักช้างแล้วอืมช้างเป็น
สัตว์ในประเทศประเทศไทยก็มีนะคะประเทศไทย
ก็มีแล้วก็ถามว่าน้องเคยเห็นช้างหรือ
เปล่าน้องก็อาจจะหมายถึงใครที่อายุน้อย
กว่าเราน้องอืมพี่ก็ได้มยพี่เคยเห็นช้าง
หรือเปล่าส่วนใหญ่เาก็จะร้องว่าน้องอืม
น้องนั่นแหละน้องเคยเห็นช้างหรือเปล่า
ช้างมันตัวโตไม่เบาตัวโตก็คือช้างเนี่ย
ตัวใหญ่ใช่มั้ยคะนักเรียนเออตัวโตก็คือ
ใหญ่นั่นแหละใหญ่โตพูดแบบนี้ครูฟ้ากับครู
เรียมเนี่ยตัวเล็กๆตัวไม่เท่าช้างนะคะ
ช้างตัวใหญ่กว่าใช่อ่านักเรียนก็ตัวเล็ก
กว่าช้างใช่ไหมมช้างตัวโตไม่เบาอืก็หมาย
ถึงแบบโตๆมากนั่นแหละอืและช้างก็มีจมูก
จมูกยาวอันนี้ช้างหรือพินอคคิโอคะจมูกยาว
จมูกยาวช้างก็จมูกยาวนะเค้าก็บอกด้วยว่า
จมูกยาวของช้างเนี่ยเรียก
ว่างวงงวงเรียกว่างวงจมูกยาวๆเรียกว่างวง
มันคืองวงนะอันนี้งวงครูฟ้ามีจมูกครู
เรียมมีจมูกช้างมี
งวงมีเียบเี้ยวใต้
งวงปกติเขี้ยวเนี่ยเขี้ยวก็
คือสัตว์ที่มีเขี้ยวใช่มยแบบว่าเสือสิงโต
เสือสิงโต
หมียวแมวเมวหมาก็มีเขี้ยวอืเขี้ยวนะคะ
ช้างก็มี
เขี้ยวแต่ของช้างไม่ได้เรียกว่าเขี้ยวของ
ช้างเนี่ยเรียกว่างาอืมจะขึ้นเป็นอย่าง
นี้เนาะงาเราบอกว่ามันอยู่ใต้งวงเรียกว่า
งานะคะเรียกว่างาอืมแล้วก็มีหูมีตาหางยาว
ใช่แน่นอนเออเพลงนี้แบบทำให้จำได้เลยว่า
อ๋อตรงนี้เรียกว่างวงนะอันนี้เรียกว่างา
อือืเพลงที่ดีกับการเรียนภาษาไทยนะคะใช่
อันนี้เราผ่านไปแล้ว 2 เพลงค่ะครูฟ้าใช่
ค่ะครูเรียมมีเพลงอะไรอีกอืเรียมกำลังจะ
หาเพลงที่แบบมันมีมันมีความหมายอ๋อกรรไกร
กรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมครูฟ้าเคยเล่นมั้ยเคยค่ะ
อันนี้เป็นเกมนิดนึงนะนักเรียนสนุกเนาะ
เราก็เล่นได้นะแบบกันแล้วเราก็จะมีการทำ
มือด้วยเนาะอืมีมือกันไกล
ไข่ผ้าไหมผ้าไหมทำยังไงจำไม่ได้ผ้าไหมทำย
งี้ผ้าไหมอโอเคแล้วก็ไข่ 1 ใบ 2 บาท
50  50 อะไรอีก 50  50  2 บาท 1 ใบไข่
ผ้าไหมไข่กรรไกรใช่แล้วเราก็พูดอย่าง
เงี้ยทั้งวันน่ะแบบกรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่
เอ้ยไข่ 1 ใบ 2 บาท 50 เียมก็เออจำไม่ได้
แล้วน่ะใช่ก็มันมาจากกรรไกรใช่มั้ยใช่ๆ
กรรไกรกรรไกรนะคะกรรไกรเพลงนี้ก็มีความ
หมาย
เออแล้วถ้าเกิดถ้าเกิดรู้ว่ามันคืออะไร
เนี่ยจะทำมือได้อใช่ก็มีกรรไกรแล้วก็มี
ไข่ที่นักเรียนกินอ่ะเนาะไข่ผ้าไหมผ้าไหม
เนี่ยเป็นผ้าอย่างนึงนะคะที่แพงเนาะแพง
พ้าไหมนะคะแต่สวยมากเลยนะสวยผ้าไทยอ่ะนัก
เรียนผ้าไทยผ้าไหมเพลงเมันก็จะร้องกรรไกร
ไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ใบ
2.50 ไข่ 1 ใบ
2.50 ไข่ 1 ใบเเรียกเป็นใบนะคะไข่ 1 ใบ
ก็ 2 บาท 50 สตางค์อือันนี้มันจะเป็นเงิน
นะคะ 2 บาท 50 อะไรอย่างงนี้ 50  2 บาท 1
ใบไข่ผ้าไหมไข่่กันกรไปแล้วเก็จะเพิ่มแบบ
ว่าสปีดไปเรื่อยๆใช่มใช่เราก็แบบจะเริ่ม
แบบกรรไกรไข่ผ้าไหมไข่ 1 ใบ 2 บาท 50  50
2 บาท 1 ใบไข่ผ้าไหมไข่กรรไกรแบบเนี้ย
แล้วก็ๆก็เฮ้ยมันเป็นเกมที่สนุกนะนัก
เรียนลองเล่นดูนะคะสนุกว่ามันจะเร็วมาก
แบบไก่ไข่ผ้าหมายไข่ 1 ใบ 2 บาท 50  50  2
บาท 1 ใบไข่ผ้าหมายไข่กรรไกรเห็นมยใช่นิว
ก็จะอยู่อย่างเงี้ยนิวก็จะอยู่แบบเนี้ย
มือขวามือซ้ายันเเนี่ยยสนุกมากอืมใช่โอ
อันนี้ก็เป็นเพลงที่ 3 อก็เอาไปเล่นได้
เนาะเอาไปเล่นได้ค่ะนักเรียนแต่เล่นกับ
ใครนี่สิาเล่นคนเดียวค่ะไกขไกถไป 250 เออ
เล่นคนเดียวในห้องก็ฝึกว่าเอทำให้เร็วๆ
เดีวทำให้เร็วๆใช่แล้วก็มีเพลงแมงมุมลาย
ตัวนั้น
ฉันเห็นมันครูครูฟ้าเคยได้ยินมั้ยครูฟ้า
อ่อทุกเพลงเลยอ่ะฟ้าอ่อทุกเพลงแว่าครู้
จักทุกเพลงใช่มมเพลงนี้ร้องว่าอะไรคะครู
เรียมร้องว่าแมงมุมลายตัวนั้นฉันเห็นมัน
สมสานเหลือทนวันหนึ่งมันเปียกฝนใช่มไหลลง
จากบน
หลังคาพระอาทิตย์ส่องแสงน้ำแห้งเหือนไป
ลับตาใช่มมันีบไตขึ้นฟ้าหันหลังหันหลังมา
หันหลังมาทำตาลุกวาววาว
อ๋อครูฟ้าจำได้มของูฟ้าเป็นแมงมุมลายตัว
นั้นฉันเห็นมันอยู่บนหลังคาอ้าเหรอแล้วก็
จำไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะน่าจะเป็นเวอร์ชั่นของ
โครเเรียมน่าจะคล้ายๆกันนะล่ะค่ะอืใช่
เป็นเพลงของแมงมุมนะคะนนักเรียนแมงมุมแมง
มุมไปทำอะไรค่ะอันนี้แมงมุมนะ
คะสไปเดอร์แมนสไปเดอร์แมนแมงมุม
ออเป็นเพลงของแมงมุมที่ปีนขึ้นหลังคาอื
บ้านของเรามีหลังคาเนาะอันเนี้ยหลังคานะ
คะแมงมุมก็จะปีนขึ้นมาบนหลังคาปีนขึ้นมา
ปีนขึ้นมาบนหลังคาอืมแล้วก็โดนฝนเปล่าใช่
มั้ยเออแล้วก็เปียกฝนเพราะว่าฝนตกเนี่ยฝน
ตกในงแมงมุมมันก็โอ้ยมีฝนตกแล้วก็ลื่นไหล
ลงมาเนี่ยอันนี้คือการไหลไหลลงจากหลังคา
นะคะก็ไหลไปจากหลังคาอือืนั่นแหละแต่พอ
เวลาที่ฝนน่ะฝนหยุดตกแล้วออแล้วก็มีพระ
อาทิตย์มีพระอาทิตย์แบบมีแสงแล้วมันร้อนๆ
น่ะอืน้ำก็จะแบบระเหยขึ้นไป
อืเราก็แแบบแห้งกลับไปใช่มั้ยใช่แมงมุมก็
จะแบบแมงเ้าบอกว่าแมงมุมทำตาวาวๆเหมือนทำ
ตาโตๆรือเปล่าตาลุกมาเอว่าในมุม
แบบเหมือนหันหลังมาอะไรเงี้ยหันหน้ามาหัน
หลังมาหันหลังหรือหันหน้า
เออเหมือนบางทีเราก็พูดว่าหันหลังมาเนาะ
หันมาหันมาอืมแบบหันมาแบบนักเรียนอยู่ใช่
มั้ยแล้วนักเรียนเรียกครูฟ้าครูเรียมครู
เรียมหันมาหน่อยเออหันหลังมาครูเรียมหัน
หลังมาออมีอะไรคะครูปาคือเรียมกำลังหัน
หน้าไปทางอื่นอยู่อืมเก็ถามครูเรียมหัน
หลังมาหน่อยหันหลังก็คือหันไปมองข้างหลัง
ออ
อ๋อค่ะเก็จะหันมาใช่ในเพลงเขาก็บอกว่าแมง
มุมก็หันหลังมาแล้วก็ทำ
ตาลุกวาวลุกวาววาวตาวาวเออทำตาโตนั่นแหละ
ทำตาแบบตาใหญ่ๆอืตาปิงๆอย่างงั้นน่ะค่ะอื
นี่แหละก็เพลงนี้มีความหมายอะไรอีกมั้ยก็
ไม่มีแล้วค่ะเป็นเพลงเกี่ยวกับแมงมุมนะคะ
นลองหาฟังดูได้แมงมุมแมงมุมแมงมุมขึ้น
หลังคาลงหลังคาแค่นี้อใช่ๆแล้วเรียมก็คิด
ว่านักเรียนหลายๆคนก็รู้จักเพลงของเด็กๆ
นะเวลาเรียนภาษาไทยอืมถูกต้องนะคะเพลงของ
เด็กๆเนี่ยมีหลายเพลงเลยเป็นเพลงที่ฟัง
ง่ายไม่ยากนะคะนักเรียนลองไปเสิร์ช Google
แล้วก็หาดูเพลงได้เลยใช่แล้วก็ร้องแบบ
สั้นๆแต่ว่าก็ร้อง้องวนไปวนไปเรื่อยๆใช่
แล้วค่ะูเรมซึ่งวันนี้เนี่ยเราก็หมดเวลา
แล้วใช่มยใช่ค่ะหมดเวลาแล้วเพิ่งร้องเพลง
ได้ 3-4 เพลงเองค่ะครูขาใช่หมดเวลาแล้ว
ค่ะแล้วเจอกันใหม่เราต้องเจอกันใหม่
วีดีโอหน้าแล้วแหละใช่แล้วค่ะต้องไปแล้ว
ค่ะทุกคนแล้วเจอกันนะคะครูป๊าบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอ